comienza el alto el fuego ordenado por
el mandatario ruso Vladimir Putin pero
para su homólogo ucraniano Voló
dimmircelenski la medida es sólo una
cortina de humo
ahora quieren utilizar la Navidad como
excusa para detener al menos brevemente
el avance de Nuestros hombres en el don
vas y acercar equipos municiones y
hombres movilizados a nuestras
posiciones
qué traerá esto Solo otro aumento del
número de Muertos
la orden de una tregua de 36 horas
respondió un pedido del jefe de la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa el patriarca kiril
el jueves por la mañana el rechazo de la
oferta por parte del presidente
ucraniano y sueco en las calles de
kievs
creo que es una hipocresía total el 31
de diciembre no había Paz estuvimos
sometidos a muchos bombardeos en
nochevieja es pura hipocresía por parte
de Putin
en Washington también se mostró
escéptico sugiriendo que el presidente
ruso estaba intentando conseguir un
respiro muy necesario
soy reacio a responder a cualquier cosa
que diga Putin
me pareció interesante que estuviera
dispuesto a bombardear hospitales y
guarderías e Iglesias el 25 de diciembre
y en año nuevo creo que está intentando
encontrar algo de oxígeno
los interrogantes aumentan sobre la
nueva táctica de Putin que llegó Poco
después de que un gran número de tropas
rusas murieran en un ataque ucraniano en
la ciudad de el día de año nuevo